hey guys tie here with another gamespot
news update on titanfall if you've been
waiting to get in on the mech where
action on your 360 I have bad news the
launch has been pushed back into April
you hear that that is a sound of
PlayStation fanboys laughing at you
fight back fight hard titanfall on xbox
360 was originally planned to launch
alongside the xbox one and pc versions
last week but this was bumped back to
Mars 28 in February the launch day has
since been pushed to april eighth now in
north america and beginning april
eleventh in europe EA executive Patrick
soderlund said I want to update everyone
on Titan fall for xbox 360 and
development with blue point games I've
been planned again a lot it's fantastic
but we see a few things and we can make
them even better so we're giving Blue
Point a little more time the game will
feature the same 6v6 gameplay maps modes
weapons and burn cards as xbox one and
pc versions of the game titanfall and
360 has been promised to be a true
first-class experience so do you guys
think the delay will help sound off in
the comments below be sure to follow all
the information on gamespot com